the head coaching jobs are filling up
fairly rapidly a week ago there were
none and now there are four unofficially
a fifth when dan campbell widely
expected to be named the new coach
detroit lions now the saints have been
eliminated but the jaguars have urban
meyer jets robert sala
the chargers
as of last night
announced brandon staley the rams
defensive coordinator and finally the
falcons have hired arthur smith the
titans offensive coordinator i was
surprised chris by
the chargers move for a couple of
reasons yes first of all first of all
there were multiple reports
that it was going to be brian dabo that
they were waiting for brian dabal to
become the head coach and maybe they
thought you know what
there's going to be some sort of a bob
lamont he's the agent who represents a
bunch of coaches gm's etc pulling the
rabbit out of the hat and getting brian
dayball to houston because he represents
dayball he represents nick casario and
he represents jack easterby maybe the
chargers were afraid that something like
that was going to happen i don't know
because uh look john
brandon's stanley i've given props he
was the john carroll defensive
coordinator in 2016. he's had a meteoric
rise he clearly knows what he's doing
i don't want a revolving door of offense
offensive coordinators for justin
herbert i don't want it you know similar
to my concerns about a defensive coach
with the jets because they got to fix
sam darden if they do whoever does it is
going to get hired somewhere else this
is even more important in my view justin
herbert guy for the next 15 years i and
he's going to get offensive coordinators
head coaching jobs because of just his
performance people are going to hire the
coordinators because of herbert his
reward is going to be now i got to work
with a new coordinator why not hire an
offensive coach like a sean payton drew
brees combination where you don't have
to worry for 15 years about the
offensive brain being pulled away by
some other team that's what concerns me
in this house oh and brandon stanley may
end up being the next vince lombardi but
that's what concerns me because you're
gonna you're gonna have new offensive
coordinators every two or three years or
maybe every year if it goes well for the
chargers no well listen you're right
that that's a real thing there certainly
there's no doubt uh you know i i don't
they're they're gonna put their their
trust in brandon staley who probably has
made them feel like hey
don't worry i'll hire the right
offensive coordinator the next time
around i know what it takes to have a
good offense or what it is he's
obviously made them feel feel
comfortable about that maybe they also
felt like
hey justin herbert you know
shane steiken steiken i want to make
sure i say his
last name the right way the offensive
coordinator of last year hey listen they
did do some good things on the offensive
side of the ball it wasn't like it was
like a bad offense we know there was
mismanagement of game situations but the
offense there's a lot of positives there
so maybe the the chargers looked at it
that way and went let's say status quo
let's change the defense up become more
multiple but they do run the risk of
what you're talking about there's no
doubt about that and again i'll echo
the chargers have mastered the nfl
information
thing
they are very good at keeping
tight-lipped and nobody having a clue
what the hell they're doing the last few
years in the draft this right here they
have thrown curve balls at the nfl
insiders and it's led everybody down the
wrong path and we don't know i thought
for sure it was going to be brian dabal
like you said first off there's a
relationship between him and tom telesco
and all the reasons you said made sense
and i would have liked to seen that but
brandon staley is a rising star there's
no question
celesco and dave all went to the same
high school crazy they were like two
grades apart in the same high school so
you know you're looking for people you
can trust looking for people that you
can you can enter into this very intense
competitive environment with who are
with you where you're not worried about
divided loyalties hidden agendas you
need everybody on the same page it's
like the old three-legged race that they
would do at the picnic where you tie
your right leg together with someone's
left leg you got to work together like
that you got to have complete and total
trust and that's why another reason why
i thought dabo would get it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports